[Music]
in Southeast Asia most rice fields use
up to three times more water than the
amount needed and suffer 5 to 10% lower
yields and reduced Milling output and
quality from an even maturing all
because most rice fields are not
properly leveled a well-level rice field
is crucial before planting your crop it
leads to even crop growth and ripening
uniform water coverage which means
Savings in irrigation water and fewer
weed problems all leading to a healthier
crop maximum yield and even better grain
quality traditionally most farmers in
Asia use draft animals and two wheel
tractors that drag Harrows and leveling
boards across the flooded fields to
level their
land an ideal way of leveling rice
fields is through laser leveling laser
leveling for Rise is slowly emerging in
some Southeast Asian countries such as
Vietnam Cambodia and La
PDR with laser leveling a laser
transmitter plays at a side of the field
sends a laser beam to a laser receiver
which is attached to a leveling bucket
drawn by a
tractor the control panel or box mounted
on the tractor interprets the signal
from the receiver and opens or closes
the hydraulic valve which raises or
lowers the
bucket the bucket then drags and drops
soil across the field to make it
even the laser receiver signals the
adjustments of the leveling bucket
accordingly to ensure that the height
distance between the soil and the laser
signal stays the same making the soil as
leveled as
possible laser leveling can be done in
dry fields thus saving valuable water
for growing the crop farmers can do
laser leveling during the dry season or
when the crop has not grown
[Music]
yet the international rice Research
Institute with support from Trimble
Company introduced laser leveling for
rise in Vietnam in 2003 by providing
equipment and training to the Baku Seeds
Center and Nong Lam
University the Baku Seeds Center has a
network of farmers who grow seeds for
laser leveling of these areas farmers
pay 50% of the cost while the government
covers the remaining
50% since their fields were laser
leveled Farmers from garai District of
Baku have been enjoying many
benefits
[Music]
foree
Mr danganan observed that households
that got their fields laser leveled now
have better livelihoods and are able to
buy the things they need such as pump
equipment TV sets and
motorcycles such is the case of Mr Fam
unl's Family whose lives have changed
quite a bit from Simply earning a few
additional Vietnamese Dong per
[Music]
Hector
farmers in anang Province are also now
experiencing similar benefits of laser
leveling Nan vanan andan fdf's field was
the first field laser level in anang in
2006 it took only 2 days to level their
4 Hector field using laser leveling
while leveling 0.3 Hector using a
buffalo used to take them through 3 to 4
days with a well- leveled field they now
use a drum seater for direct
seating before it took them 30 person
days to manually weed their unleveled 4
hectare field now that they use a drum
seeder that plants seeds neatly in rows
weeding takes only 4 days using a row
weeder with her leveled land fertilizer
is spread evenly resing in in less
lodging golden apple snails which used
to hide in uneven spots can no longer do
so they have reduced their fuel for
pumping water from 20 to 30 L of diesel
to only 7 L for all four hectar they
saved even more water from adopting
alternate wetting and drying which
allows them to alternately flaw their
field at times and let it stay dry for a
few
days
danan vanai a farmer who is part of the
one must do five reductions program in
anjang is also reaping the rewards of a
well-level field as he applies the best
practices taught in the
program
for lyuk a progressive farmer from 3on
District anang borrowed the laser
leveling equipment from Nong Lam
University bought his own tractor and
Laser leveled all of his 150 hectare
Rice Field over the last three
[Music]
years seed production he says has higher
value seed since then his yield has
increased by 0.7 ton per Hector and his
income by
30% in the future he plans to build more
mechanical flatbed dryers and Seed
processing
equipment Dr F Yu Yen Erie post Harvest
consultant estimates that in Vietnam
about 300 hectar of Rise Fields have
been laser leveled with more than 200
100 hectar in the mechon
Delta I think the the news
has spread enough uh from the high level
official to the ordinary people and uh
today I can say that it's an equipment
that will change the
arure especially the rise arure in a
very Major Way in this
sector Now with an urgent need to ease
the labor shortage by using agricultural
machineries such as combine Harvesters
laser leveling is being reintroduced in
neighboring
Cambodia in November 2011 the irrigated
rice research Consortium and the Erie
Asian development Bank Post Harvest
project organized a laser leveling
demonstration at the Don Bosco School in
batambang Province almost 100 extension
workers farmers and students attended
the
event the goal is to increase ride
production and the Royal government yes
has just put in place a new policy to
improve ride production and also to
export me r on our
own uh we have to have uh what we call
uh appropriate farm management
techniques that will range from uh land
preparation to harvesting the
crop for the policy to be uh
successfully implemented uh farmers will
have to come back to the technology like
Laser Land leveling uh as it is one of
the many options or solutions to achieve
that
goal with combined efforts from National
partners and renewed Vigor to promote
the technology more farmers in Southeast
Asia will benefit from laser leveling
and the many advantages it
[Music]
brings
a
n